[Music]
i figured it out yeah seven times a
charm
don't be an actor oh god
you don't belong with those la folks
they're a bunch of fascist hippies
[Music]
brings you here and i figured no better
place to be discovered in the
supermarket hey did i see you on a
television series you do movies you
don't work in any team industry at all
no man
you don't know you're fussing with this
truck i'm a son i'm just boring it i
reckon it's a few months worth of
cleanups on aisle four to pay off a dui
impound
what can i get for you miss i got beef i
can see that
hey
hey
let's not waste either of our time i'm a
catholic why ain't that what confessions
were you can't date someone who wasn't
baptized
i thought you was gonna say hispanic
where's the water i'll do it now i know
i'm not what you're used to
and not what you deserve either life's
gonna give you a gut full of reasons to
be angry
you only need one to be grateful
i think god saw something that you were
saving
but it's up to you to decide what you've
got to offer
it's a place you told me you believed in
me i thought it makes sense being back
here to do this
your son is about to make a huge mistake
i'm going to be a priest
for halloween
i'm praying for you bill don't you dare
you're violating my right there's a man
going around taking names we've all been
wrong and we've all done some wrong but
he came to forgive us everybody won't be
treated all the same there's no easy way
to deliver this news you have a
progressive muscle disorder the muscles
weaken until he ceases to function is
there anything it doesn't mess with yeah
erectile function
i'm trying to be a priest pal the wise
men will bow down before the throne oh
no i don't know
why it's late
wow
man don't lose when he gets knocked down
the money won't get up
[Music]
a baby
there is concern amongst the diocese
that your infirmity will render you
unable to be a priest listen to the
words long written down what you guys
get one phone call a week in here who
you gonna call huh when no one else
gives a [ __ ] what you got to say god
does when the man who comes around he
ain't giving up on you don't you dare go
giving up on yourself hear the trumpets
here
100 million angels singing where are you
going i got to get your ass to church on
time
who are you here to visit sir father
still
you and everybody else
[Music]
we shouldn't pray for an easy life
but the strength to endure a difficult
one
[Music]
well you can't say i never gave you
nothing yeah i skipped over thanking you
went straight to the source
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you